so every time I do an episode of comics
and coffee a lot of the questions I
would get asked centered around who
would win and theoretical fights between
superheroes so what I thought I would do
is test the waters and try my hand at
answering some of these questions and
since the flash television series is
returning this week I wanted to feature
Barry Allen but ran into the problem of
who from the model universe would be an
interesting and worthy companion in
recent years the flash has seen a
significant increase in his power level
within DC Comics so much so that a
battle with his closest analog in the
Marvel Universe Quicksilver wouldn't
really be fair
as Barry would win with almost no effort
so in order to pair him with someone
that could hope to match his speed and
power what I want to do in this video is
figure out who would win in a battle
between Barry Allen and knowing rad the
Silver Surfer so in order to answer this
question we have to first look at the
forces that give each of these
characters their powers with that in
mind we'll start our discussion with an
explanation of the Speed Force the Speed
Force is a concept with NBC comics that
was created during the lightning strike
that gave Barry Allen his SuperSpeed as
it was established by Geoff Johns in
2009 s the flash rebirth
when Barry runs he generates the Speed
Force and it's expanded to exist
throughout the DC multiverse as a
kinetic wall of positively charged
energy all the speedsters within the DC
Universe can access the Speed Force and
when one of them dies they merge with it
as a kind of afterlife to this end all
the powers and abilities of the
speedsters are derived from the Speed
Force itself the primary and most
obvious of these powers is superhuman
speed which also includes superhuman
reflexes agility cognition stamina and
healing now Barry Allen SuperSpeed is
well documented in comics as he's
performed several feats that indicate
meta speed is practically limitless as
an example of just how fast he is
during the final crisis event it was
established that while we as the reader
had believed Barry Allen to have been
killed during crisis on Infinite Earths
in truth during the 24 year window
between that story and the events of
Final Crisis Barry had actually been
outrunning
death it's also been repeatedly
established that very can travel much
faster than the speed of light and has
even been able to run so fast that he
can manipulate the space-time continuity
most famously done during the flashpoint
event when he ran into the past and
prevented his mother from dying and so
in addition to almost limitless speed
Berry is afforded several other powers
by the Speed Force including the ability
to vibrate himself at such a high
frequency that he's able to face through
solid objects and even the barriers
between dimensions
Barry can also produce cyclones by
rotating his arms and can generate
enough electricity to throw lightning
arcs at his enemies and Barry's
durability is also increased due to an
order of kinetic energy that surrounds
him another notable ability possessed by
the flash is the infinite mass punch the
infinite massed punch is possible when
the flash is running at a speed close to
the speed of light which causes him to
gain mass relative to that speed and
allows him to deliver a devastating
punch now as to the actual force of the
punch it was described by writer Grant
Morrison as being equivalent to the
power of a white dwarf star
and although this description applied to
Wally West punch it stands to reason
that we can apply the same logic to
Barry Allen as well since they're both
able to access the Speed Force now
having said that I want to turn our
attention to the source of the silver
surfers powers the power cosmic the
power cosmic is a force within the
Marvel Universe that seemingly
originates with Galactus who is able to
bestow the power on individuals that he
chooses to serve as his heralds if you
want to learn more about the power
cosmic you can feel free to check out my
video from earlier this month where I
give a full explanation of it but while
he was in the service of Galactus
Norrin Radd the Silver Surfer came to be
in possession of the power cosmic now as
far as to what the powers capable of the
list is seemingly endless but it
includes superhuman speed strength
stamina and durability individuals
imbued with a power cosmic can also gain
the ability to manipulate matter itself
to this end the Silver Surfer has been
able to create entire cities and even
atmospheres and can also use this
ability offensively as she's been known
to reduce his opponents to atoms
furthermore the Silver Surfer is able to
use the power cosmic to create immensely
powerful energy blasts and is used them
to destroy enemies starships and even
plan
he can also manipulate energy to
teleport across galaxies and can convert
objects into pure energy in addition to
this the Silver Surfer has demonstrated
an ability to manipulate gravity to the
point of affecting the orbits of planets
now much like the flash the Silver
Surfer is able to travel it unheard-of
speeds and one instance he's traveled a
distance of five hundred thousand
light-years a distance nearly five times
as long as a Milky Way galaxy in a
matter of seconds meaning that much like
Barry Allen he can travel at a speed
much faster than the speed of light at
the same time the Silver Surfer has
repeatedly demonstrated super speed
having shattered walls made of the
nearly indestructible metal vibranium
and breaking apart a planet made of
asteroids that he was trapped inside now
all that being said the question becomes
this who would win in a fight well to
answer this question we have to lay some
ground rules under normal circumstances
the flash has to have friction in order
to run so if the battle occurred in
space the flash would be automatically
outclassed as there'd be no surface for
him to run on so for the purpose of this
battle both combatants will be placed on
the earth so that flash can take
advantage of the planet's gravitational
pull and the friction that the planet's
surface will provide adding this
stipulation will also make things more
interesting as it negates the silver
surfers ability to destroy planets as
the surfer has been shown on multiple
occasions to have an affinity for earth
and would therefore not result to
destroy the planet just to win a battle
still even with those caveats in place
the Silver Surfer has a clear advantage
in terms of pure power the flash has
proven to be extremely powerful with his
arsenal of arc lightning and especially
the infinite massed punch however even
if he hit the Silver Surfer with the
infinite mass punch which would unleash
the power of a white dwarf star on the
Silver Surfer the server would
undoubtedly be able to survive it as
he's flown through a red dwarf star at a
speed faster than light without any ill
effects
in contrast the Silver Surfer would be
able to harness the power cosmic to such
an extent that he could atomized the
flash if he so choose or in the
alternative hit him with energy blast
with enough power to destroy a planet
on the other side of the coin however
the flash is arguable advantage in this
contest is his speed now it's almost
impossible to definitively state which
one of these characters is faster
traveling at top speeds but I'm willing
to say the flash has the advantage here
and what I'm basing this conclusion on
is a fact that the flash has actually
moved fast enough to travel backward and
forward in time and while it's true that
the Silver Surfer is able to time travel
as well this seems to be something that
is simply inherent to the power cosmic
itself instead of a product of the
SuperSpeed that is supplies furthermore
we've seen in the recent flash comic
book series that speedsters can increase
their speed by taking on the speed of
other speedsters so the flash is able to
convince other speedsters to give up
their speed which has happened recently
he may be able to push even further
ahead of the server and so even though
the flash comes to have the edge in
speed this is a battle and it's not a
race and even if the flash can outrun
the surfer initially he would eventually
have to engage the surfer and even if he
was able to travel fast enough to evade
the surface attacks while the Speed
Force does supply Barry with ample
energy unlike the surfer Barry still
needs to consume food to maintain his
body's metabolism meaning that without
complex carbs proteins and fats he would
eventually be overcome with fatigue and
be forced to recover at that point I
think it comes down to the question of
whose attack power durability and
healing are more advanced than the most
recent issue of the flash we saw Barry
Allen having to take time to recover
after battling the villain Godspeed in
contrast the Silver Surfer seems to be
virtually indestructible with his
healing virtually instantaneous so while
the flash would be able to use his speed
to outrun the Silver Surfer initially
and keep things interesting I think that
in the end the Silver Surfer significant
advantage in power will allow him to win
the battle but with that being said if
you could take any speedster regardless
of who they are and put them against the
Silver Surfer who would you pick I'm
kind of curious and if you guys are
interested in more videos like this make
sure you hit the like and sub button and
make sure you post down below which
characters you think I should have faced
off against one another keep in mind
we're strictly keeping our contents
limited to comic books
that being said I will catch you guys
later peace
[Music]
you